ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخدير العسكري والاستراتيجي لوقفايز
مرحبا بك دعنا نبدا بالمعارك التي تدور في
المطار مطار الخرطوم الدولي
واقرار الجيش على لسان البرهان اليوم انه
لا يسيطر عمليا على المطار ماذا يعني ذلك
يعني لا يتجال المعارك تدور بشكل او باخر
في داخل المطار ومحيط المدار المطار
وبالتالي لا يستطيع اي جانب ان يدعي
السيطره الكامله على هذا المطار علما انه
خرج عن العمل مبدئيا ولو بصوره جزئيه
وتوقفت حركه الطيران واستخدام هذا المطار
كما اشارت تقرير كما اشرت بانه احد
الاهداف
الحاسمه التي لابد ان يتم السيطره عليها
وهي المطار والقياده العامه والقصر
الجمهوري وبالتالي من يسيطر على هذه
الاهداف الحاسمه الثلاث ليستطيع ان يقول
انه صاحب اليد العليا مبدئيا في معارك
الخرطوم بابعادها الثلاث مدينه الخرطوم او
الخرطوم بحري او ام درمه طيب ليه واقفه
اليوم ايضا سجل دخول تعزيزات عسكريه من
طرف الجيش السوداني الى مدينه الخرطوم ما
دلالات التي يمكن ان تحملها هذه الخطوه
هذه الترجمه لتصريحات للفريق البرهان في
اليوم الثاني من العمليات عندما تحدث
واشار بانه قد يقوم بنقل قوات من المناطق
الهادئه والتي يستطيع ان يستخدم بعض
القوات الموجوده فيها مثل قضاء القضارف او
ولايه وادي النيل وما شابه ذلك اي من
الولايات القريبه من ولايه الخرطوم وهو
بالتالي هو اولا بحاجتها من اجل استيعاب
التمدد الذي جرى من قبل قوات الرد السريع
ومن اجل تحقيق انتصارات في الاماكن التي
لم تستطيع
الجيش السوداني ان ينجز ما هو مطلوب منه
ونعود هنا الى الاهداف الرئيسيه ثلاث هذه
القوات اذا وصلت يمكن ان توظف لتعزيز
القوات المتواجده سواء في محيط القياده
العامه او القصر الجمهوري او المطار ولكن
بالنظر الى طبيعتها هي قادره على الحسم
باعتقادك
يعني موضوع الحسم هو كلمه ضبابيه الان هل
الحسم هو حول هذه الاهداف الثلاث اذا كان
الحديث عنها في اطارها الجغرافي الضيق
المحدود نعم هذه القوات اذا وصلت بالاضافه
الى اي تعزيزات اخرى يمكن ان تحقق ذلك
الحسم الجزئي ضمن اطار الاهداف الحاسمه
لكن الحسم في مدينه الخرطوم الكامله اعتقد
بعيد المنال من قبل جانبي الصراع طيب ماذا
عن وضع قوات الدعم السريعه حاليا
قوات الدعم السريع من عام 2019 استطاع ان
يدخل حوالي 40 الف من اصل مئه الف موجودين
في ولايه الخرطوم ويبدو كان هناك توافقات
سياسيه او الظروف الزمنيه عملت على طرفي
الصراع الحالي ان يتحدا في مواجهه الثوره
التي جرتها الحراك السياسي الذي جرى لانه
باعتبار جميعهم داخل الزي العسكري
وعليهم ان يحفظوا دورا للقوات المسلحه
ولكن يبدو ان كل جانب كان يهدف الى شيء
غير معروف للجانب الاخر حمدتي يبدو كان من
البدايه يسعى الى الوصول الى النقطه التي
وصل اليها قبل سته ايام وهي ان يحاول ان
يفرض السيطره لهذا السبب سمح له بالتمدد
سمح له بادخال القوات لغايه 40,000 سمح له
بالسيطره على بنك العديد من المقرات
الحكوميه والان اصبحت هي شو كه في قاصره
الجيش السوداني لواء فايز ماذا عن طبيعه
المعارك والمواجهات الدائره في الابيض
وايضا ما اهميتها بالنظر الى الصراع بين
الطرفين
يعني الان الخارطه الجغرافيه نحن نتحدث عن
18 ولايه نتحدث عن ثلاثه ولايات رئيسيه من
حيث المساحه وقد تصل مساحتها الاجماليه
الى 35 الى 40% سواء الولايه الشمال
دارفور كردوفان بجزئياتهم هذه الولايات
بعيده نسبيا
وتاثيرها المباشر على مجريات المعارك داخل
ولايه الخرطوم محدود ولكنها تاتي ضمن اطار
الرؤيه العامه لمن يسيطر على السودان
مستقبلا لانه اذا استطاع على سبيل المثال
قوات الدعم السريع ان تسيطر على المقرات
الرئيسيه والمعسكرات والفرق في كردفان او
في دارفور يعني ذلك انهم تمكنوا من
السيطره على اجزاء كبيره من جغرافيه
السودان وهنا تدخل العمليه كلها في دوامه
لا يمكن ان تنتهي وقد يكون
عمليه ما جرى في ما اطلق عليه لاحقا جنوب
السودان بعد 23 سنه من ثوره ادت الى
انفصال السودان الجنوب السودان شكرا جزيلا
لك لواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي ضيفنا من عمان